hey everyone welcome to Simon dev in
this project I'll show you how to build
out a rock-paper-scissors game in
JavaScript we'll just use plain vanilla
JavaScript here with no bells and
whistles so no additional libraries no
crazy 3d stuff just the basics like
always the code is all available on
github so take a look if you're
interested the link is in the
description below I've tried to clean up
the code as much as possible
anyway what we'll go over today is the
rules of the crazy version of
rock-paper-scissors from Big Bang Theory
basic implementation of
rock-paper-scissors in HTML and vanilla
JavaScript and I'll walk through the
code with you going into more detail
into the thought process behind certain
design decisions so first the rules
I'd love to include a clip from the show
here but having no idea what the rules
are around fair use all err on the side
of caution and just include a link in
the description below normal
rock-paper-scissors is pretty simple
each turn you've got three possible
choices rock paper or scissors each of
which can be beaten or beat one of the
other choices so rough beats scissors
scissors cuts paper paper covers rock
let's make this just slightly harder by
implementing the more complex version
from the show shall we
first up the rules as Sheldon explains
scissors cuts paper paper covers rock
rock crushes lizard lizard poisons Spock
Spock smashes scissors scissors
decapitates lizard lizard eat paper
paper disproves Spock Spock vaporizes
rock and as it always has Rock crushes
scissors the rules are much more complex
but not super crazy so you can see that
each choice now beats two of the other
choices and loses to two of the other
choices and obviously ties with itself
so here Spock smashes scissors and
vaporizes rock but paper disproves Spock
and lizard poisons Spock every one of
these has two possible losing choices
and two possible winning choices making
it just a little bit messy to write a
big nested if statements
see this works but I think we can do
better instead what we can do is
structure the data so that we don't even
have any if statements at all so that's
the rules out of the way let's start
thinking about how the code should look
first off let's represent the winning
and losing states in a structured way if
I wanted to look up say who Spock beats
looking at the diagram it's easy we can
see Spock beats scissors and rock which
immediately implies that any other
choice beat Spock in fact the same holds
true for every choice lizard beat Spock
and paper which then implies that lizard
loses to rock and scissors in fact rock
smashes lizard and scissors decapitates
lizard
so this naturally follows into a super
easy way to store the data let's make a
dictionary and when we look up a value
say smock each entry itself will be
another dictionary with the choices that
Spock beats and how to phrase it in the
UI so if I were to write this choice is
equal Spock and the dictionary here
scissors smashers and rock VAP rises now
we contribute look up whether Spock one
against another choice by reading let's
say the choice is rock here so choice
equals rock and if choice is in choices
then we can log that Spock beats that
choice so now we can go back and fill in
the rest of them Spock smash the
scissors and vaporises rocks scissors
cuts paper and decapitate slizzard and
so on this is our victory function so
given two choices then we can in a
couple lines with very little effort
look up who won or lost now let's go
over the rest of the program let's start
with the index.html this is a few lines
of HTML and what we do here is include
the base stylesheet which includes any
CSS that we want to style a page with in
the body here there's two main sections
to the body the header which just
corresponds to the title that we have up
on the screen here there's the score
here on the left in the HTML which we'll
modify from code and it shows up here on
the right
the description which is what we write
the winner loser text in so when a game
is finished we can write something like
player wins scissor cuts paper and this
is the general purpose div that will
hold all the buttons for all the icons
for each of the choices so each of these
rock-paper-scissors lizard-spock things
will show up here in the setup code here
we make icons for each of the choices
and insert them as children of the
selection div and we set them all to be
unselected initially we're using the
styling to control whether or not
they're selected so we just include
selected or unselected in the class name
and a small thing to call out here it's
easy to miss we add an on click handler
to each div what this does it notifies
us that the player has clicked on this
div that naturally leads us to show how
that function works so let's scroll down
there in the Select function what we
first do is go and loop over every div
and set them all to unselected and then
for the specific one that was chosen and
we can find out exactly which one was
chosen by looking at the events current
target see when we made the ID the same
as the name of the choices so that we
can look things up easily and we assign
that to a global player choice finally
we call AI choose and this all it does
is randomly chooses one of the options
see here all it's doing is randomly
choosing one of the options the logic in
here is just to animate the circles a
bit but we could also trivially remove
that let me go do that
and now it finishes immediately now so
there's no animation you can see that as
soon as I click on one of these the game
ends and a winner or losers decided and
the way that it finishes is it calls
resolved winner so let's scroll down to
that and this looks a lot like the code
we went over earlier doesn't it we do
some quick lookups using the AI and
player choices and from that we can
determine the winner without a crazy
nest of if statements and that's it
that's our paper-rock-scissors in
JavaScript implementation you can
trivially add more options by adding
more
and then editing the dictionary at the
top the advantage here is that we
structured the data really nicely and so
this can be extended trivially I hope
this was easy to follow and if you
enjoyed the video and want to see more
like it hit that subscribe button in the
corner also let me know what you'd like
to see in the future by leaving a
comment below until next time cheers
everyone